All right.
Turning to some business news today.
A baby company
known for its super soft
sleepers is facing a
rough reaction online
after it
reportedly fired a new mom
who requested to work remotely
so she could stay in the neonatal ICU
with her
adopted baby
who was born at just 22 weeks
I will never give my baby
another dime of my money
and I would encourage her to do the same.
These are the people we're supporting.
Kate brought this on to themselves
after treating their employee so bad.
All right.
So we are obviously talking
about the brand. Kate, baby.
You can see one
mom even taking her child's pajamas
and throwing them out into the snow.
Now, the mom story that we just heard
there went viral on TikTok,
but the situation for the company
then took a turn for the worse
when the CEO posted this apology
to the employee on TikTok.
I wanted to help.
I'm here
to sincerely apologize to Marissa
for how her parental leave
was communicated and handled.
It was my oversight
that she didn't feel supported,
as we always have intended.
I will be reviewing our policy
and procedures to make sure
to avoid hurting our staff
and our community in the future.
All right.
Let's bring in
CNN's Pamela Brownell, who's
following the story for us.
So, Camila,
a lot of people called that response
that we just heard.
They're canned.
It's been called overly scripted.
And then the CEO issued a second apology.
So what's the reaction
been like to these
to these new apologies
from the new mom
at the center of this controversy?
What more do we know about that?
Overall, people are just not happy
with the situation
and with the response from the CEO.
And she was essentially forced
to publish that
second apology video on TikTok,
because as you mentioned,
a lot of people
just saying, look, it sounds scripted,
it sounds like you're not being genuine.
And then on her second video,
she then admitted it and said, yes,
it was scripted.
And that's why
she went off
script that second time
and apologized again
and said that she regretted having told
Marissa Hughes
that she was not allowed to work
remotely.
Take a listen to the second apology video
This was a terrible decision.
I was insensitive, selfish.
I cannot imagine
the stress she had to go through.
I fully realized the
impact of my action,
my decision, my shortsightedness.
So here's the backstory.
This all started in December
when Marissa Hughes
and her partner decided to adopt a baby
that was born prematurely.
When that baby was born prematurely,
it was put in the NBCU.
And so she had to be there with her
baby now.
Company policy is for a person
like Marissa,
who had not been with the company
for at least a year.
She only got two weeks of maternity leave
and after that maternity leave,
she was asked to sign a contract
saying that she would work
at least six months
minimum after her leave,
and she was unable to sign that contract.
Because her baby was still in the NBCU.
And so the company released a statement
saying that, yes,
they told her that
she could not work remotely and also said
that essentially her job was still there.
This is obviously after the fact,
after the criticism.
They said
initially they did not think her job
was something that she could do remotely
but that now
they're still offering her her job.
She posted a video on social media.
You see it right there on your screen.
That's Marissa.
And she said she acknowledged the apology
but said she didn't think
she could return to work
and then also said she was encouraged
by the changes
that are happening in the company
because now
the company says
they're revising their policy.
And so that is, of course, something
that a lot of people say is good
and they're welcoming that decision.
But there's still
so much
criticism on social media
for them being a baby company
that then did not allow her
to be with the baby when he
was in the nick. You
know, really interesting story there.
Camila Bernal live for us in Los Angeles.
Camila, thank you.